FRANK: So today we're going
to see a guy name Joe,
and he's been restoring
multiple buildings
throughout the city here.
MIKE: This is it right here.
FRANK: Oh, this is--
this is cool.
MIKE: See, I like this.
Coffee bar.
FRANK: I could do a coffee.
MIKE: Hey-hey.
JENNY: Hi, welcome.
MIKE: How're you doing?
FRANK: Hello.
MIKE: Hey, is Joe around?
JENNY: This is Joe.
MIKE: Hey, you Joe?
Hey, nice to meet you, I'm Mike.
This is Frank.
FRANK: Just like the coffee.
Joe, you know?
MIKE: Hey, I'm Mike.
JENNY: Hey, Jenny.
MIKE: Nice to meet ya.
JENNY: Hi, how are you?
MIKE: Is this your place, Joe?
JOE: This is Jenny's.
MIKE: Danielle was telling us
on the phone that you've got
a lot of buildings down here,
and you guys have been
working with Main Street.
JOE: Yeah, we got ten
downtown buildings in all.
MIKE: Really?
In this town?
JOE: In this town, yeah.
MIKE: Really!
You guys want to show us
around a little bit?
JOE: Oh, okay.
MIKE: Yeah, I'd love
to see what you're doing.
JOE: We've been successful
with the buildings
that we've done,
and success breeds success.
People see you do it,
then they'll do it.
JOE: This is the old
Hopkins County Bank.
MIKE: Wow, look at this, Frank!
Dang!
FRANK: This is like
a staple of the city.
MIKE: Wow, this is cool.
FRANK: Wow.
MIKE: Dang, man.
Oh man, look at that ceiling!
FRANK: Wow.
MIKE: Whoa.
How high is that?
JOE: That's 32 feet.
MIKE: The inside
of the place is like...
Ralph Lauren meets
Jeremiah Johnson.
There's canoes, there's guns,
there's taxidermy;
but then you have the
backdrop of this bank.
MIKE: What is this place?
JOE: A place to store
stuff that I collect.
[laughs]
FRANK: This is your...
MIKE: So, this is your man cave.
JOE: [laughs] Yeah!
MIKE: This is cool, man.
FRANK: Gonna look around
here a little bit.
You got...
This is just right up my alley.
What about this item here?
JOE: Yeah, that's a Warren
Paint Company display.
It was in a,
you know, a store...
FRANK: Sure.
JOE: ...and it sold paint
and varnishes out of it.
Warren's was
a Nashville company.
FRANK: Obviously
this would be quart-size,
pint, half-pint...
JOE: Yeah.
FRANK: ...and
just a little guy.
I mean, and it's...
JOE: Yeah.
And there's storage,
down below...
FRANK: Down below here,
you would actually open it up
and then you have product.
JOE: Uh-huh.
But it was on the floor of
one of their stores, I'm sure.
FRANK: It's a really,
really cool piece.
FRANK: Whatever
you put in there,
it's gonna look beautiful.
JOE: Yeah.
FRANK: What are
you thinking on this?
JOE: What would you do?
FRANK: I'd do $1,100.
And I'd load it myself.
[laughter]
JOE: How about 13,
and I'll load it?
FRANK: 12 and we both load it.
JOE: Alright.
[laughs] Yeah.
FRANK: Alright.
You got-- alright.
Alright, [laughs].
You're gonna help me now!
You said, you said.
MIKE: Hey, how about these
three big green lights?
JOE: Oh, the industrial lights?
Uh...
I'll take 200 apiece for them.
MIKE: [whistles]
500 for all of them.
JOE: How many's up there?
MIKE: Three.
JOE: I'd do 550 for them.
MIKE: How about 525?
JOE: Alright.
MIKE: Alright, we're doing it.
JOE: [laughs]
MIKE: It takes people like
Joe and Jenny, collecting,
restoring, rebuilding,
to make things happen.
JOE: Alright.
FRANK: See ya, Joe!
Take care!
[honks horn]
JOE: Alright,
see you later!